- Hey Gar, I got us friendship milkshakes!
(yelling) what the hell?
- Please leave for the day.
- What, milkshakes, why?
- I have a girl over,
she thinks I live alone.
And I just, come on, I
haven't gotten any strange
in weeks.
- But--
- Come on, I'll pay you back later, maybe,
sometime, probably not.
- I left my stuff inside.
- Take those straws out
of your ears, you look
like a while devil.
- Son of a bitch.
- [Operator] Whoa whoa
whoa, what are you doing?
- Operator?
- [Operator] You shouldn't be here.
- I was just trying to
call home and say hi
to my mom.
- [Operator] Hang up now.
- Sorry I don't have any bread today guys.
Hope we can still be
friends, where you going?
Okay.
I miss my mom.
(chattering)
- Yeah.
- Give me a hug.
Okay, bye.
- Bye.
- [Kate] Finally!
- How?
- [Kate] Well I didn't do well
out I the real world, Garrick
so I came back here, I was
going to hang out in the
back yard but I figured it
was close to your bedroom,
so I sat on the front porch,
then I thought you'd see me,
so I came up here.
- Yeah, good plan.
- [Kate] Yeah, also do we have a ladder?
All the steps I saw on the
way up disa-friggin-ppeared
on the way down.
- No, no we don't have a ladder.
- [Kate] Okay, well can you go find one?
- You want me to just go
up to a neighbor and say
"oh hey do you have a ladder available?"
- [Kate] Yes.
- I'm not gonna frickin'
do that, why would I...
You just throw an acorn at
me, that's not even an acorn
tree, where'd you get an acorn from?
- [Kate] Bitch, get me a ladder!
- I swear to God, I
fucking hate this garbage.
Kate, this is Tyler, he has a ladder.
- Hi.
- Hi, hey, nice to meet you.
I actually don't need a ladder anymore.
I'm okay though.
- Oh, what a re-leaf.
(sensual music)
- Okay, well I'm glad
that's over, right guys?
We can move on with our lives.
- Do you like goat milk ice cream, Tyler?
- No.
- Me either.
Do you wanna go not eat some inside?
- Yes.
- Hey, um, your ladder!
It's not fair...
Oh come on, you guys
aren't even gonna hook up
anyway, you're on your period!
- You don't know that!
- Yeah I do man, look I
got the little schedule.
- So you knew how rude today was.
You are gonna stay out here
until I'm good and done.
(stuttering)
(funky music)